big Tom New England sports fan we loved
him in the Commish the shield Fantastic
Four love them and Gotham especially
also American Horror Story none other
than the great sweetheart Michael
Chiklis good to see you sir what an
intro no it's a hell they can't mean
every word do so flattered I love when
you come here thank you continue coming
back and you just sit here and we just
chat little chitchat sport you know in
life and you had to show judge of course
crucifying the ball as he does and he
terrifies me he's he terrified well yeah
as a desert Red Sox fan he's pretty
terrifying and so is that entire lineup
i I think every single one of the of the
nine have 20 home runs right that is
correct first team ever have 20 home
runs from every spot in a pitch a
pitcher facing them that's just misery
but the Red Sox usually we can get in
this year despite you wearing your
Edelman Jersey which we'll get to in a
second the Red Sox you know is that is
the fact that the Red Sox know how to
pitch these guys though normally and
last year when they were facing this
this team as a young team and brockman
you can attest this fact that they know
exactly how to make these guys chase
they throw high in the zone and a lot of
these guys tryna as you say you know
crucify the ball and and they swing
through it I mean that read though just
the way the Red Sox play baseball scares
Yankees fans too and I guess that's what
makes it a great rival it's the greatest
thing in the world the fat I hate
seasons where the Red Sox or the Yankees
are lacking it's it's never as good as
when we faced each other right I mean it
just is better and especially when you
have I mean how many teams in the
history of the game have have won a
hundred and two games in or in second
place right right do you have that well
this is the first time that the Yankees
and Red Sox have ever faced each other
in the playoffs where both of 100 games
I mean they're both magnificent they're
both healthy coming into it the
interesting thing to me is that they
they are the actual games between them
all year haven't been really good I mean
they've been blowouts they've been sort
of one-sided blowouts for the most part
and they haven't been that interesting
it's like they start tagging somebody
and they you know and then they just
have a batting practice day you know
just bomb the crap out of the other team
but I don't think that's gonna happen
now well it's gonna be a war it was damn
near wrong I mean I tread 19 games the
Red Sox won 10 the Yankees won 9 it
really was right down the middle and it
was funny I follow Pete Abraham who
covers a 10-4 they what the the globe
right yes okay he tweeted out during the
game last night
Luke Voight is the odds-on candidate to
charge a mound I tweeted him back you
know only if not if Joe Kelly behaves
himself yeah yeah like there's gonna be
something that happens here yeah this is
watching right since that rivalry is
alive and well it seemed like it waned
especially after we won a handful of
championships but now it's alive and
well
we're hating on it's gonna be like the
fact it's 5 games I like the fact that
it's it's it's more of a you doing
crucible yeah I do
more pressurised that's for sure yeah I
like that it's 5 games that it's right
out of the chute I like the fact in all
honesty that it's all the pressures all
on the Red Sox that they could be one
and done which is exactly the way a
Yankee fan wants to do this 180 2004 see
you back to 2004 after being after being
taken out like that yeah I got it I
totally get it now would be a great
piece of revenge that's all built in
vengeance you just said it spiteful
human and you're not and you're not even
though I can't reduce you as a
sweetheart you've got it in you come on
now you don't want it you don't want
this so very bad oh my god but you know
it's easy for me to say now that no 7 is
the proper way to do it because then
you're gonna see there a real
representation of who is the better team
here you have gonna but all of what you
say makes sense for a Yankee fan and
also
[Laughter]
the numbers are even with Dell - phobia
yeah yeah may I continue I go on because
my series with a five-game series v
being the decisive game the way things
are set up it's gonna be David Price
versus the Yankees ah and that is
usually more often than not a come on
taste a feast a Derek Jeter homering off
of home run but he wasn't pitching
pitching for us then what happened to
the love man that is still love like him
you just introduced me with all that
love and everything I know how it's
still love let's move over under on
Judge Stanton strikeouts this series it
could be very hot because like I said
the Red Sox know how to pitch these guys
and they want to chase the high stuff so
bad and Sanchez batting eighth or this
could be the moment that they all gel
together and off the who's gonna be
Scott Brosius who's gonna be Aaron Boone
that's right
Luke Voight you guys always have those
get one guy that always killed us Gary
Sheffield Hideki Matsui used to always
get JD Martinez is that guy for the Red
Sox right now he's never been in a
situation like this so he's never faced
this type of pressure just you wait just
you wait well this is gonna be terrific
right he seems to have ice water in his
veins man I think he's gonna be fine
yeah yeah and he he's a ball where are
you watching it are you taking it in by
yourself with your family with friends
and family yeah we have our you know
like tonight I have a bunch of
knuckleheads from New England coming
over the house to seattleman return we
do this we you know there there's a
bunch of us here do you serve New
England clam chowder
theme theme no no it's just we do not
invite Yankee fans real quick so last
night last night okay I'll tell you
watch the game last night with my kids
okay and they were all over the pose
don't forget to and I've got two puppies
it's just insane in my house right now
and I'm trying to focus and it was not
very easy
my wife Susie wants to make sure
everything's fine as she was going out
with friends last night okay so she made
me before she left some like turkey
meatballs and kale kale that we've grown
from our own bed okay I like that okay
and the kale
despite her washing it very well ended
up having gritty a worm in it oh that's
worse so then we washed it again she put
the worm in the turkey ate the dinner
then found yet another worm later on oh
and the reason why I'm telling you this
story is i stoled Susie this as she
laughed when she came home serves me
right for eating kale during Yankee play
right okay let's face it it's never
meant to be consumed you know what I
mean like so that's why I asked you
about if themed flavored food is that
you know you got us we keep it I mean
like we don't go for you know it's not
like I served shouter
I mean lobster lobster a little kid
you're loving but today it's not tights
not of any concern to you come on you
know it's not you know it's not well
they're banged out sure like crushing
the Colts because let's not forget who
started what deflate get yeah
yeah you're sad sham that false piece of
I'm gonna start smart
man that was dangerous that was right
president yeah my top teeth hit my
bought my bottom lip with the and all's
history holds true it's not gonna be
close right the Patriots have won seven
straight by an average margin of victory
of nineteen and tonight is it tight is
big in this respect okay it's a
nationally televised game everywhere
there's a lot of people gonna see it but
it's the first time that we see Gronk
and Edelman Josh Gordon so many Michele
behind Brady like where this is it now
okay yeah and by the way too
let's not forget this piece that I think
New Englanders might not be thinking of
mm-hmm the gentlemen who left the Colts
at the altar in the non playing session
Josh McDaniels was set to be their coach
this was supposed to be
Patricia Park where Patriots are taking
on another one of their former it's not
12 rebels gonna be that later on in the
season when the New England visits
Tennessee but yeah
you mean McDaniels want to win this one
and the worst way to but I just don't
think they're equipped with the way that
they're banged up short we coming in and
Brady Gronk
Edelman Josh Gordon you know you're a
great Vrabel story please when I met
variable I met him a backstage at the
ESPYs with when you know 2002 well I you
know this is back in the day yeah just
know I was here in LA and they just won
the Super Bowl and I had just done well
and I ended up there and here comes here
comes you know a bunch of the Patriots
backstage toward me and I pick up I pick
out the biggest one and it's variable
right and he really looks like what
Superman should look at right I mean at
the time he was in a tuxedo and he
looked like he could go like this and
just fly away you know I mean was he
like six seven 240 no body fat he's
coming up to me so I go right up to him
and I'm like five nine on my birthday
and I come right up to him and I go the
harder you fall mother you know
you say that's release the first opening
line and he bursts out laughing and
Pat's me on the top of like what you do
to your plug Tom Brady I set myself up
to fail that's those are the best fandom
stories is that you just show your great
fandom out and these guys have fun with
you it was great it was great yeah
let's talk a little bit about this book
right here let's talk about smothered
yes well your daughter's book I'm
incredibly proud of my daughter and
obviously but it's a rare thing when a
22 year old right out of college comes
up with an idea and it was based on text
messages back and forth with her mother
she you know my wife's a little crazy
you know 30 years and she's hilarious
and you know she'll say things right so
for instance my daughter went mom um did
you tell the waiter that you were my
stepmother no no well yeah because he
knows you're 21 and I can't have a 21
year old mother stepmother so she
screamed grabs that puts it on Facebook
next thing you know 500 likes sure yeah
people so she starts to do this and she
realizes that all of these little
interactions with the mother are getting
incredible interaction and she decides
to create a narrative tying all these
things together sort of like The Nanny
Diaries and it's just an incredibly
smart witty funny you know it speaks to
Millennials in their helicopter mothers
right it's really really funny so she
gets the concept together she pitches it
she sells it at 22 writes it in her 23rd
year and now she's 24 and she's a
published author and there's some great
news coming out about the the furthering
life of this but I'm not allowed to say
it no but that's really her news but I'm
just really really proud of her it's
really funny and any any woman is gonna
read this in just how okay it's called
smothered and it's available where books
are sold online and I know you guys in
the audience but guys you want a great
gift for your girls so we got a lot of
women
it this is it cuts across so it's true
now did you thank for that no of course
and so I'm proud I can tell but you know
it's my kid of course uh you know it's
not often that a 24 year old writes a
novel you know it just isn't is ottoman
New England sports fan as well
hardcore now come on now died no yeah
okay are you kidding me no I'm just
trying to do the hair Easter right I'm
just trying to do the math though so
this is pre she's a little kid and this
is pre Red Sox winning it all pre bring
at all she suffered with me okay all
right although you know especially my 19
year old she has they have no idea so
idea for it being nineteen years old
she's seen us just become title time and
everything she's like oh yeah you know
my second oldest nephew my second oldest
nephew and my oldest nephew I'm on my
wife's side of the family my
brother-in-law was holding him in his
lap and I think age to three weeks
watching Brady beat the Rams in the
Super right see he's grown up you know
number times I tell him I doesn't have
memory of no idea that Red Sox that the
Celtics the Bruins I tell the story of
my grandmother all the time when we won
in O four I think I told this on this
show but really quickly I was alone in
Vancouver shooting the Fantastic Four
when we won and I sat there with a
bottle of 25 year old Macallan and I
refused to pull the cork until the final
out because I'm from New England and we
can't coerce so I'm like and then it
happens pop I'm screaming out the window
at the poor Vancouverites the poor
Canadians below the bambinos dead he's
dead and they think I've been saying
that my phone rings and I and it's my
yeah my grandmother mmm she goes the
last time these effing guys did this I
was one she was 86 so you know no one
like anybody but I was 40 so when we won
our first title you know in all those
years so I was long-suffering I mean we
did have we did have the Celtics of the
80s which was fabulous
like one of the greatest the greatest
franchises it's true it's true when we
did up to seven the early 70s with the
Bruins but I mean as far as the Red Sox
are concerned in the end the page
it's Oh God yeah it really is amazing
that the Patriots for an entire
generation are viewed as the winning is
franchise for good reason and everybody
burned before that there's a generation
before including Bob Kraft himself sat
on those metal which and bleachers
you know tell me if you feel the same
way I'm gonna pay a compliment now okay
I appreciate you fine that's a great way
to bring us awful sir I finally
understand what it is to be a Yankee fan
Oh
based on the Patriots do you follow me
there well I mean I guess if the amount
of hate if we hold on a second if we
hate for sure the hate and and and and
people denigrating your success trying
to put the asterisk for dear life but if
you don't mind me saying
the analogy only works if you include
Super Bowls and dog ears you know
champion I thought you were my friend
compliment and it's just he turned it
into ground like this is what I deal
with every day there's every every Super
Bowl championship counted is 735 and
whatever it's a terrible house let's
text each other with respect
I don't say this though from a
philosophical standpoint I can't tell
you how many times
something has happened during a sporting
event I have picked up my phone to go
tweet about it and I go Eisen get out of
my brain because you have tweeted what I
was going to say I love it it's so true
and I just end up going to like before
you say anything good luck to you served
here's man I don't mean it Michael
Chiklis on Twitter check it out we
follow each other it's great follow
smothered by autumn Chiklis I'll check
it out there it is your your daughter's
book a novel I'd buy it for your wife
buy it for your daughter here you got a
laugh together check it out right here
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience